hey everybody welcome back to some
titanfall 2 videos in today's video
we're going to be discussing about how
to win more games in the attrition game
mode now if you are not familiar with
the attrition game mode it is a fan
favorite game mode that was in titanfall
one that was brought back to the second
it was brought into the second game and
it is one of the two most popular game
modes in titanfall 2 now I made this
video because the it's Christmas it's
going to be Christmas in a few days and
a lot of Christmas students are going to
be getting on and then they're not going
to know how to play some of the game
modes are going to be little bit
confused so I made this to kind of help
help them grow or kind of help them get
better at this game so in teaching them
some tips now the first thing you need
to know about attrition is that it's a
66 game mode where six pilots versus six
pilots can face off against each other
when and then eventually they can call
them their Titan after their meters been
filled up and there's also some AI
grunts specters and Reapers the Reapers
are toward the end of the game the
grunts are toward the beginning and the
Reapers kind of filling in the middle so
some of the tips you want to use in the
game that I've come up with are always
kill the AI toward the early game
because usually when you spawn you're
going to each of the players are going
to split off into different locations
and then you're probably going to run
into some a i always kill the AI there
quick easy points to get your score up
and if i didn't mention already the
scores to 500 so these games take about
10 to 15 minutes to complete but do be
aware though killing the AI will give
away your position by you showing up on
the minimap and enemy pilots can also
hear your gun going off another way that
you can further improve your win status
in this game is by helping out teammates
in need if they're in a Titan help them
if you're in a Titan kind of double team
with them if you can tell that they're
getting double-teamed even out the
playing field so it's an even to v2 or
if you're not in a touch if you're not
in a Titan you're a pilot and your
teammates getting destroyed in a 1v1 or
1 V to fight the other time with your
anti o Titan weapon you know use the MGO
grenade launcher use the archer all
those types of weapons or even you could
rodeo
now for asking what the most popular
anti Titan weapon is I'll have a video
on that in the next coming and the next
couple days still working out some of
these statistics for some of the weapons
now as I said before you could rodeo
these Titans rodeoing a Titan will hop
will make you hop on the enemy Titans
back and rip out their battery what you
can do with the battery is give it to
your own Titan or a friendly Titan to
further give them more health and then
give them a shield now this is super
useful because it keeps your tight ends
in the game and in the fight longer and
Titans are huge tied to the battle so
always having more Titans is an amazing
idea also speaking of batteries never do
this I've had this happen to be four
times you're going to look like a dick
doing it never if you see a teammate and
their battery was stolen and you kill
the guy that stole their battery don't
hop out and take their Titan or take
their battery and give it to your Titan
it was their battery and they lost help
from it so you might as well give it
back to them it's the once again to
further increase the amount of titans on
your team by having everyone at high
health as much as possible now the one
thing you want to know is the point
values for each of these enemies the AI
is the Reapers the pilot and Titans all
have point values when they are
destroyed the ai's grunts inspectors
which are toward the beginning and
middle of the game they have one point
for each kill the Reapers that come
toward the end of the game have five
points when you kill a pilot you also
give five points killing italian is 10
points so if you kill a Titan and its
pilot before he can eject or you execute
him that's 15 points but these are how
to win this game mode I hope you all did
enjoy and for all the new players that
have seen this video I hope this did
help you start off titanfall 2 and I
hope you enjoyed this game later as you
play and that'll be it guys peace out